les responsables Ukrainiens ne
décolèrent pas pour eux l'alliance
transatlantique fait preuve de faiblesse
après avoir refusé d'instaurer une zone
d'exclusion aérienne en Ukraine
à cause de l'OTAN et son refus d'établir
une zone d'exclusion aérienne d'autres
civils vont être tués depuis les airs
par les forces russes d'autres enfants
vont être abattus et le sang des
Ukrainiens va continuer à se déverser
sur les réseaux sociaux volody
mirzelinski et même aller plus loin
affirmant que l'OTAN a désormais aussi
sa part de responsabilité dans la
tragédie ukrainienne
les gens qui mourront à partir de
maintenant
mais pour le temps c'est pour leur une
ligne rouge un franchissable James
toltonberg s'est expliqué la mise en
œuvre d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
passerait par l'envoi d'avion de chasse
dans l'espace aérien de l'Ukraine puis
l'éventuelle élimination d'avions russes
pour la faire respecter avec le risque
d'une guerre totale en Europe nous ne
sommes pas partis prenantes de ce
conflit et nous avons la responsabilité
d'éviter l'escalade au-delà de l'Ukraine
l'alliance engagée depuis plusieurs
semaines dans des manœuvres dans des
pays frontaliers veut éviter à tout prix
une confrontation directe et le Kremlin
est catégorique sur ce point tout pays
qui imposerait une zone d'exclusion
aérienne serait considérée comme Kobe
tout mouvement dans cette direction sera
considérée comme une participation au
conflit armé et une menace pour nos
militaires
pour l'heure l'Union européenne et les
États-Unis se sont engagés à continuer à
livrer des armes aux forces ukrainiennes